what does success look like as you when
you guys work you know like how are you
like is there something you can measure
towards because it's such a big
complex problem what's your piece that
you can affect or what what is it what
does it look like when you guys get a
win
yeah i mean certainly we there's certain
um
legislation we've worked on where we've
seen that be successful in passed
we've seen how our research has
contributed to you know policy wins
and a greater understanding of an issue
so we can certainly see that you know um
i think that some of our work at insight
we really are
sometimes um
ahead of where other folks are and
they're thinking and i say head like
future thinking i mean
you know we'll put an idea out there and
initially people will say wow that's
kind of crazy
so i mean for example we
are very much our work is centered on
racial equity
and you know we've come to really think
that racial equity is also becoming kind
of muddied like what does it mean how do
you know you're successful how do you
measure it
and so we really you know start to think
about
a foundational architecture of our
economy that's built on
anti-blackness right um and i'll explain
that in just a second but
you know um so we really we developed
this
this this framework that says you know
we can we can center blackness and
policy
right to address anti-blackness and
really address the most marginalized
um and so some people see that as
radical
but it's a logical framework to solve
for racism embedded in our economy in
our politics and so
that's what i mean by kind of pushing
the envelope on some of these issues
so when we think about anti-blackness
and i call it a foundational
architecture because our economy was
built on this very notion
of anti-black racism and
when we think about how our economy was
shaped
through slavery right that
this was not just you know the fact that
there were some plantations and some
you know slaves in the south worked on
them this was a global economy
right um and it
it it really allowed us as a nation to
develop
like business models from this
architecture right
um yeah how we thought about collateral
how we thought about depreciation
even how we thought about labor and
how you can actually yes and how you
could really
um you know extract from labor how you
could
force labor to be more productive right
and you know we can see it today in
surveillance and we think about how we
can push
workers to produce more um
so this isn't something that this is
very foundational to our nation's
economy
but also to the rules of our economic
policies
right i just talked about the social
safety net and our social safety net
is predicated on tropes like a welfare
queen
uh narrative it is it's it's even when
people say when you think about poverty
who do you think about
right and people often say black people
right um
and because of that you know
we have very punitive systems and so
what if we really just thought about
um considering the most marginalized and
and thought about
what would what would it look like in
our policy if we can
actually solve for anti-blackness that's
a new way of thinking about racial
equity
um and i think it's a very unifying
actually it's a very it's a way to build
solidarity because we're
all impacted by it think about this
right so when you think about medicaid
expansion
and the fact that a lot of states chose
have chosen not to expand medicaid
and you listen to the narratives behind
that it's these same kinds of things
about
deservedness who is it hurting yes
it can be it's hurting black people but
it's also hurting white people and maybe
even
to a greater degree right so these you
know
anything that's really predicated on
this notion ensnares everyone that's in
it
ensnares everyone that has to that needs
that policy that needs that program
um you know to survive uh to be able to
be you know moved up economically
uh it's it's it's really fun it's
something that we don't talk about
because it's just
so it's so difficult for us to think
about
our economy in that way but when we look
at a lot of policies you can go back and
see how they're
how they're embedded in anti-blackness
and why
we can't move the needle on certain
policies
thank you for sharing that and i think a
lot of the bigger challenges
you're right is that it's less than the
policy it's more on the narrative too
because there are certain sides on the
right
they actually don't want to hear that um
or it's tough for them to hear that
um probably because it cuts against the
first narrative that they earned their
way
right the current system was
successful from a dollars and cents
standpoint um
you know we became the wealthiest
country in the world so that's i think
just the numbers
but um busted and twisted and it's in
how we got there
um and
it's now at a point where
sure we're still like you have more and
more and more and more people
piling up at the bottom um and
i'm at the point now and i think many
are what it needs to be fundamentally
shifted and so you can't you can't tweak
on the margins you can't change the
inside
has to be fundamental and that's what
always drew me the universal basic
income
it drove me to cash payments that sort
of cash relief because it would
fundamentally
start it wouldn't be the only
fundamental but it would start to
rewrite the rules of the economy where
you
basically your income level doesn't
start at zero
um in your view
um you guys are based in oakland um
which
uh nearby stockton california was the
first city to really pilot
basic income on a cash relief standpoint
or if you wanted to start rewriting the
fundamental rules like how would you
how would you go about that right let's
say hey i had the money and i had the
political will and skill to execute it
what does that mechanically look like on
your end
and then maybe we can back into the
narrative that needs to happen to do
that but mechanically and casually
what are you how would you envision that
from your end
what's really amazing about the pilots
that we're seeing is
it's it's helping us really think about
how we can design
an entire system right it's it's really
um shredding those myths about what we
think
cash would do right it was just everyone
was geared up to think this is gonna
you know what's gonna happen people are
gonna go out and
not know how to spend the money and this
wouldn't you know make a difference
but what we're seeing is quite the
opposite and
i think you know one living here in
california
knowing that you know wages really just
can't keep up with the
cost of living even with high minimum
wage wage laws here
um that the cost of living is
outstripping um
wages that this this
like pilot of 500 a month made a
significant difference in people's lives
i mean it enabled people to to actually
work more enable people to take care of
their families meaning
those who are caretakers and and and
we've got to think about
the the the care infrastructure i mean
it's it's critical and
coming out of this pandemic it it helped
people
you know pay down debt it helped people
which i think is one of the biggest
issues
it gave people a greater sense of
peace of mind it helped people deal with
the stress
and that and all the things that
manifest from stress
from being short on money every month
and so
it's teaching us that we can really have
a new way of operating in this country
if we think about
um really moving away from punitive
approaches
and really helping people get what they
need
and and trusting them to say i know
what's really best for my family
i think you know even looking at the
pilot in jackson mississippi with
with black mothers and saying you know
finally like i can take my kid to the
ocean
you know i can get the extra help in
school
um all the things that make our lives
worth living
you know and i think that uh you know
those
those of us who are really really
believe in in cash
see it for all of those reasons see it
for people's ability
to really be who they're meant to be i
mean it's not going to solve
every issue but certainly it can solve
for
you know being able to say i don't have
to worry whether i'm going to eat next
week
you know i don't have to worry if i have
to juggle between trying to keep the
lights on
and figuring out how to take care of the
needs of my child so
yeah i think that it's it's it's
providing us
with an opportunity to reimagine um a
broken
really you know broken systems that have
been in play for for decades
for us the press narrative that was so
frustrating was that people said andrew
was going to
um get rid of other benefits in addition
to cash and
never said that he said on the on the
margins you could opt in
but never ever said um and he never
would like he's like the point like if
you any anyone really listens
like why is he running is to fix it not
to cause more problems jeez
[Music]
you